hi I'm Eric Voss and incredible Sue's
huge success has meant millions of fans
have been delighted with intricately
designed action layered humour and
clingy moms eating bow babies and like
any great Pixar film incredibly Stu is
bent with subtle design details that you
might have missed and nods to other
Pixar movies
so let us rewatch this movie scene by
scene and break down all the Easter eggs
and then scrub them down like babies
come on I really can't get past that
opening charts spoiler warning if you
didn't see the movie yet and let's get
started for the movie even begins notice
how the animators updated the routine
fanfare for Pixar and Disney giving
Cinderella's castle a bit of a makeover
with this red and black two-dimensional
incredible styled look and as it fades
notice how the front windows remain lit
which giving us the Incredibles i2 logo
now this movie's story begins
immediately after the first movie ends
with the under miners attack on
municipal we see the families final
mascot moment now from the alternative
angle of Toney riding jur the kid who
had just asked out violet at the track
knees now tony is recounting what he
witnessed to rick dicker the government
superhero relocation guy from the first
movie he White's Tony's memory in the
same way and with the same device as the
one that he used on khari the babysitter
in the Jack Jack Attack short they may
have noticed that Dicker's voice has
changed the original actor voice Tim was
but lucky a longtime Pixar animator who
passed away earlier this year now the
character is voiced by Jonathan banks
the gruff character actor who plays Mike
and Breaking Bad a better call Saul
along with Bob Odenkirk who voices
Winston Dever in this movie actually
there was a later scene that shows how
an emotionally hugging and thanking
dicker for everything which to me seems
like kind of a subtle tribute by Pixar
to their beloved team member now this
whole opening section delivers on the
promise of the first movies ending
showing us the entire Parr family in
action the under minor is voiced by
actor John Ratzenberger who is made of
oka cameo in every Pixar movie the other
minor caves in the ground beneath a bank
to rob it the municipal credit union
which could be a subtle nod to the MCU
which joins the Pixar as part of the
Disney family now in the background of
all this we can see violet and Dash's
school which has a mascot of the
Spartans
that's actually the mascot of the high
school that the director Brad Bird went
to Corvallis High School in Corrales
organ and if you look at the sides of
the build
here what you should do in every Pixar
because there's always Easter eggs there
you actually see some shoutouts to some
people who worked on the film one of the
sign says Christophe which is a nod to
Anthony Christophe the movies art
director and if you look closely you can
see the sign grinning before it in
Nicole Grendel a producer in the movie
and yeah in general during the scene
throughout the movie you probably
noticed that the cars in the building's
the clothes they all reflect a retro 60s
design there's been a lot of talk over
when exactly The Incredibles takes place
there was a newspaper in the first movie
that said in 1962 when director Brad
Bird said that he just wanted the movie
to feel like the 60s the Municipal Hall
has a greenish dome which depicts our
animators lifted from the real-life city
hall of Emeryville California that's
where the Pixar studios are located
let's move on to this motel that dicker
puts them up in it's called the Safari
Court which is an animated version of
the real-life Safari Inn in Burbank
California and we see the Parr family at
dinner and most of the voice actors have
returned in their roles here Bob Parr
mr. incredible is once again voiced by
Craig T Nelson and Helen Elastigirl is
voiced by Holly Hunter Sarah Vowell has
come back to do the voice of violet but
they had to change it up with - in the
first incredible Spencer Fox voiced him
but now his voice is too grown-up he's
gone through adolescence so they
replaced him with actor Huck Milner and
they used archived recordings of the
same baby that boys Jack Jack in the
first movie - voice I'm here notice the
Chinese food takeout cartons that
they're eating out of this same carton
shows up in a lot of Pixar movies Bug's
Life Toy Story 2 monster's inc
ratatouille and inside out then Frozone
voiced by samuel l.jackson joins up with
Helen and Bob and hands them this
business card for Winston Dever notice
the address 1200 Park Avenue that's
actually the current address that Pixar
Animation Studios in Emeryville the dev
tech skyscraper is very interesting look
to it who are the animators they
designed it to look like stacks of poker
chips as a way to reflect that gamble
that these characters are making to work
with the dinners then upstairs we meet
Winston and his sister Evelyn now this
movie doesn't try too hard to hide the
fact that Evelyn will later be revealed
as the movie's true villain first her
name is Evelyn Dever
and if you just enunciate the syllables
differently you get Eve I'm trying to
kill you or yeah evil endeavor also
she's voiced by Catherine Keener who
recently played missing Armitage in get
out she's a villain who hypnotizes her
victims just like Evelyn doesn't this
and Evelyn's earrings have an
interesting design but hold on to that
one because I'll come back to it later
and Winston tells him the story of how
their father once admired the old
generation of supers including Dyna guy
and gazer beam these are both callbacks
to the first movie Dyna guy was the
super who got sued and his beam was
killed by syndromes robot on the island
we also get another call back to the
first movie during Winston's sales pitch
you can see the screen behind him shows
Frozone fighting that robot and by the
way this whole idea of supers needing to
stand up and become their better selves
to carry the burden of society has been
interpreted by some as an example of the
socio political ideology known as
objectivism that's furthered by the
author an R and Brad Bird is actually to
come out and refute any political agenda
in these movies and later when Helen
calls Winston back to tell him she'll
take the gig the area code is 5 10 5 10
is actually the real-life area code of
Emeryville Helen's new job allows the
family to move into this dev tech
mansion it's design actually reflects
the modern architecture of the mansion
in the movie North by Northwest
Winston says over the phone that the
place belongs to an eccentric
billionaire who wanted to enter and
leave his home unnoticed and that sounds
like a nod to Bruce Wayne whose mansion
also features a secret entrance through
a waterfall and as the family moves in
we see that Bob actually kept his old
fan posters from the first movie now
that we've moved into the movie second
act we see how Bob and Helen reverse
roles from the first movie now Helen is
the one going out to be the breadwinner
as bob has become these stay-at-home
parents and throughout this subplot at
the home we see some interesting details
Jack Jack's crib has a luxo ball design
referencing the ball that appeared in
the first Pixar short it shows up again
and again and picks our movies and later
in the movie inside Jack Jack's crib is
this action figure the animators have
said that they snuck in an Easter Egg
for Toy Story 4 somewhere in this movie
I'm wondering if this action figure is
that throughout the movie characters
watched TV shows from the 60s like Outer
Limits and Jonny Quest Jonny Quest has
actually been mentioned by Brad Bird as
a major influence on his career in
animation the word quest actually shows
up a lot on buildings in the background
in this movie we also see that Bob still
drinks out of the same coffee mug from
his time working at ensure care the
insurance company in the first movie bob
has to help - with his math homework
called new math new math was actually
the name of a new educational standard
in the 50s but here it's more of a
parody on the recent Common Core
standards that have been driving parents
crazy
not the way we learned it and Jack Jack
fighting the raccoon was such a great
fight scene and we had to see him use
even more of his long list of powers in
total in this movie we saw 17 different
powers let's run down all of them he can
make multiple copies of himself he can
turn into this purple demon thing when
he's angry doesn't get his nunim cookie
you give bursts into flames like the
human torch you could shoot green lasers
out of his eyes he can grow to larger
sizes at some point he can teleport into
a different dimension also proving the
existence of other dimensions he can
copy physical features of other people
he does that with Edna mode he
definitely has super-strength we saw him
tossing lawn chairs he also seems to
have invulnerability because yeah he
beat that raccoon without a scratch on
him he could definitely levitate and he
has telekinesis it was shown when he was
fighting the raccoon and remember he
lifted the goggles off of his mommy's in
telekinesis and then he shoots up like a
rocket when he sneezes you can emit
electricity he can phase shift through
solid surfaces he could transform into a
super heavy metal form he could
transform into a shapeless gelatinous
blob and you could argue that he's
capable of mimicry impersonating Edna's
walk and her mannerisms after just a few
days yes I considered that a superpower
Bill Hader is my hero now we also see
the ramifications of Toni's memory-wipe
and violets subplot in her high school
the inside of Tony's locker contains a
campaign sticker reading Deana for
president that's an odd 2d NMR sigelei
AC she's a Pixar character artist
campaigning against Deana is Matt
Johnson seen in the banner in the
background of this scene Johnson is a
software engineer for Pixar now Bob
calls dicker to track down Tony and in
Dicker's file you can see that Tony's
address is 206 South Ferris now that's a
nod to Pixar animator Justin Ferris and
as they catch up with Tony at his job in
the happy platter diner the interior of
the diner is modeled on the Cafe 101
diner in Hollywood I love that place
meanwhile Helen is the one having all
the fun boiling crimes a new urban and
there are a ton of Easter Egg nods to
Pixar in this whole sequence okay here
we go
Wow an address on the Nanyan it's
one-zero-zero-one west cutting which was
the original street address for Pixar
Animation in Richmond California then on
the hover train platform a poster in the
background may look familiar
that's the original poster for Disney's
monorail in 1959 and the number on the
hover train is a 1 1 3 a 1 3 shows up
again and again and every Pixar film and
a lot of animation it refers
a classroom number at CalArts where all
these animators studied it'll come up
again in this movie on the streets Helen
passes a sign showing Miller a nod to
Tom Miller a Pixar set dresser she also
passes a hallucinatory rat who Luth the
movies production coordinator in a sign
[ __ ] image I for Brynn image is the
shading art director and then as Helen
jumps the bike into the building she
leaves a sign for a triple dent gum the
Pixar version of Trident gum that's the
gum from inside out remember it had that
add jingle that will get stuck in your
head sorry I reminded you and when the
rooftop scene hats on also has a luxo
ball design in another building and has
a sign for Nulty industrial a nod to
Matt Nolte of Pixar's art department ok
well a non-visual plot detail that
actually reflects this role reversal
between Helen and Bob notice the way
Helen stops to train with the train cars
slowly grinding to a stop before merely
toppling over the edge this is actually
the same way that Bob stops the runaway
train at the beginning of the first
Incredibles movie actually you can see
now how Helen has learned from that
experience those people were all pissed
off at Bob she makes sure to check in
with everyone to see that they're okay
moving on to this phone call between Bob
and Helen there are actually two pretty
interesting details here the newspaper
article she's reading is written by a
guy named team a thought of the
affiliated press and that's not to The
Associated Press and Ted math OTT is a
storyboard artist for Pixar now there is
a second really interesting visual
detail here in the scene I'll get to
that in a second but first thanks to our
sponsors Skillshare for helping us make
this video Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes and designed business technology
and more it's premium membership gives
you unlimited access to high-quality
classes on must know topics so you can
improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
now I'm a screenwriter but I didn't go
to film school or anything because my
parents made normal people money but
it's all good guys because now we can
use online resources like Skillshare to
catch up I'd like to Kevin kavas feature
film screenwriting the first 10 pages it
reminded me how critical it is to hook
an audience right away which is why I've
now started beginning these videos by
shouting jokes at you Skillshare is also
more affordable than most learning
platforms out there an annual
subscription is less than $10 a month
try finding a film school that
reasonable and we're gonna do a special
offer for you guys the first 500 people
to sign up with the link in the
description below will
their first two months for free just go
to SK l dot sh / new rockstars 5 or
click on the link in the description
below okay back to this phone calls
scene with Helen and Bob check out the
painting behind Helen there are 5
geometric shapes one thin one off to the
right with the other four off to the
left this image reflects the park family
with each shape representing a different
member of that family and Helen is the
one on the far right it's reflecting her
separation from the rest of the family
and she takes on this new role now later
Helen goes on a talk show where she runs
into ambassador Henrietta Selleck her
name is actually a nod to Henry Selick a
longtime animation director for Disney
in a 70s and 80s he later went freelance
and worked on The Nightmare Before
Christmas and Coraline the character
Selleck is voiced by actress Isabella
Rossellini known for her role in the
David Lynch movie blue velvet The
Ambassadors blue velvet wardrobe may be
a nod to that movie then after the
screen slaver hypnotized as a talk-show
crew Elastigirl chases down the
helicopters to save the ambassador and
on the buildings of the background are a
couple more nods to Pixar names
there's sailor vision for Rick Sayer a
longtime technical director for Pixar
and hailstone for Jeff stone an
assistant editor for the movie meanwhile
back at home the stresses of Bob's new
role started to weigh on them check out
this scene with Jack Jack this moment is
reference to the movie poltergeist and
which actor Craig T Nelson played a
different father trying to follow his
kids disembodied voice echoing from
another dimension in his house Jack Jack
dimension table actually begins with him
staring at a TV screen just like Carol
Ann's did
and notice what Jack Jack is watching
that's actually a clip from the
superhero documentary that opened the
first incredible movie later Bob sees
his old car the incredibile now one by
collector at auction on TV and this
collector is actually an old reused
character designed by Pixar his original
name was Alexander gall Pocky
he was going to be a rival designer and
mortal enemy to Edna mode but that whole
subplot was cut so they reused his look
here - asks is that if he plans to steal
the car back and Bob thinks about it for
a second and then says no I feel like
this could be a nod to OJ Simpson the
reason OJ eventually did jail time was
for trying to steal memorabilia that
used to belong them but now ass later
bought by a collector also later in the
collectors home among this vehicle
collection is Lola agent coulson sports
car from the agents of shield show in
desperation bob takes Jack Jack to Edna
mode boys once again by director Brad
Bird Edna designs a protective suit for
Jack Jack and a baby monitor Type
Indicator of witch power he's about to
use and this whole scene is another
example of this role reversal between
the spouses it's a recreation of that
moment when Helen visited with Edna in
the first movie with Bob now in the
sliding chair and here Edna mentions
Jack Jack listening to the music of
Mozart which is another callback to
babysitter car e in the first movie and
in Jack Jack Attack remember she tells
Helen that listening to Mozart makes
baby smarter and and the short Mozart
seems to unlock more of Jack Jack's
powers and jumping back to Helen she
tracks down the screen slaver as he
delivers his chilling rant about
society's dependence on technology and
yeah it was pretty creeped out of that
shot of Elastigirl stretchy and open the
locks of the room with three slivers
stand on the other side of the door
watching her like I'm supposed to be
scared right now in this office are tons
of books and printouts about hypnosis
and one of them features this AI logo
with the spokes coming out this is the
same design of emmalin's earrings that I
mentioned earlier though of you somehow
didn't put together that she was the
villain maybe this super subtle design
detailed it for you as I'll have to go
wrestles with the screen slaver who's
actually an innocent hypnotized pizza
guy you can see on the desktop behind
them is this lamp this is the luxo lamp
from the luxo shorts and every Pixar
opening title and then when Elastigirl
knocks the screen slaver to the street
below look over to the right and you can
see this truck this is a 60s retro
design of the Pizza Planet truck which
is another detail that shows of
and pretty much every Pixar movie
Elastigirl celebrates with a bunch of
other supers gathered by the Devers
there's he lectric screw shower brick
screech and reflux and then there's Boyd
who's a nerdy fan of last a girl she's
voiced by Sophia Bush though her
character evokes Kristen Stewart quite a
bit in this section Evelyn reveals
herself to Elastigirl as the villain she
paralyzes her with these hypnotism
goggles
while explaining her motives to
Elastigirl she referenced is Albert
Einstein's time as a patent clerk which
is actually a nod to the movie
ghostbusters when Venkman says the same
thing to defend inventors humble
beginnings i Stein did his best stuff
when he was working as a patent clerk
you know how much a patent clerk earns
it's here in the movie when everything
goes to hell for the heroes last a girl
mr. incredible Frozone and the other new
heroes all get hypnotized forcing -
violent jack-jack to escape the mansion
in the incredibile and they chased down
the Dever yacht by shifting the
incredibile into hydro mode which was
actually a setting that was teased in
the first movie when mr. incredible
initially scrolled through the various
options meanwhile on that boat several
ambassadors and supers gather and check
out this one female super she isn't
given a name but this character was
actually originally designed to be honey
that's frozen's wife who me you know
doesn't really get along with Brad Bird
just thought it would be funny if the
character was only heard off screen but
they wanted to use that design in this
big group shot and the ambassadors all
sign an international superheroic or to
legalize super heroism and a close-up of
this document has a ton more Easter eggs
so let's peek through much in the upper
right corner the document header says
a113 and I already got into the nod with
the name Henriette Selleck but the next
one down is Wieck on for Yasmin kana
pics are rendering supervisor but that
is a berry yarrow for Allen berry ro he
directed a pixar short Piper for which
she won an Oscar
beneath a MS Hulu th-that's the
production designer I mentioned earlier
and then on the right column there's Ian
M SEO for Ernesto named SEO it picks our
digital painter beneath him is P ting
for Philistine a digital artist and then
ke yoku for Korea yoku it's a character
animator who helped to actually design
the Asda bike and then our brillante for
Rodney brillante Pixar's feature film
department manager and then in this
third act lots of fun madness follows
leading to the supers regaining control
and mr. incredible using the vessels
anchor to change its trajectory away
from the city actually on the deck - and
violet debate over wind
retract the anchor with eyelid shouting
push the button and - responding not yet
that's another callback to the climax of
the first movie Evelyn Debora caiied I'm
gonna kill you tries to escape in a
plane even shooting up to a high
altitude to deprive Allen of oxygen even
her hypoxia but we actually get a
reminder of Helens training as a pilot
if she's able to overcome this and take
Evelyn down with the help avoid and mr.
incredible Frozone stop the boat from
ramming the city nice the closing
sequence of the film contains a few more
Easter eggs finally gets a second shot
with Toni and you could see a poster for
happily ever after dance
that's a meta joke about this being a
happily ever after a portion of movie
and as the family drives violet and Toni
to their date the car passes another
sign for triple dint gum
remember it's the one that gets stuck in
your head yeah sorry and lastly the
movie theaters marquee displays the film
dementia 113 just kind of a double
easter-egg dementia 13 is actually the
name of one of the early movies directed
by Francis Ford Coppola long before
directing The Godfather
also you may have noticed that the a is
discolored making an a 1:13 stand out
the last referenced at CalArts classroom
what happened to all these animators in
that freaking classroom it's starting to
get creepy cry for help oh and if you
stuck around for the credits there's one
last little bonus detail the Underminer
got away earlier in the movie so he's
still at large
and at the very end of the credits we
get one last little reminder of that
with his drilled tank crawling across
the screen but a question I'm curious to
know from you guys who do you think is
the most dangerous villain of these
Incredibles movies syndrome or Evelyn
flash screen slaver
and sure you know what let's throw the
Underminer in there he is the only one
still out there
comment with your thoughts or tweet me
directly at EMS like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rockstars we
deep dives in all the stuff you love we
did a breakdown of Koko last year and we
also do videos about the Lego movies
thanks for watching and kids if you feel
a rumble beneath you
it's the Underminer coming to burrow
into your room snatch you into his big
vacuum
and all that will be left of you here
screens going through the earth drowned
the trilling grinding them is hell barn
beast don't leave loose ends Pixar I'll
turn him into ghost stories